each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
okay our second talk in the session is
by Bertrand Meyer who also presented at
the first rotor rfp workshop two years
ago Bertrand is professor of software
engineering at ETH Zurich he's also the
co-founder of eiffel software he's also
an active participant in the ACMA
standards process for the CLI and of
course for Eiffel his talk today is on
scoop concurrent object-oriented
programming for rotor thank you very
much sorry possible title for this token
in for anything that i can describe
about scoop would have been something
like how I wasted six months of my life
this was this was a while ago I spent
six months of malaya of ilife staring at
this piece of code here and after after
a while you know they had to put me on
artificial feeding and they were
debating about the ethics of the
situation and so on and I just couldn't
reconcile myself to what was happening
in a concurrent context now this is the
kind of code that I typically look at
and usually doesn't bring me into that
kind of situation there so this is is
going to be there to take a cue and it's
going to take an element and try to put
it into it and as you can see there is a
precondition that says that the but that
you should not be full and if that's the
case well the post condition is actually
not as expressive as it could be but we
won't go into this for the moment so
this is great great because I can use it
as an APR so I don't even see you need
to see what's in the do part but i'm
going to write things like this and
still fits your sleep at night right bi
I have my cue and if it's not full and
because of the precondition and I'm I
entitled to put something into it now of
course from cuse there's a similarly
seemingly easy step to two buffers right
so this becomes concurrent and well over
all hell breaks loose because between
the time I test for the Cure not being
full and the time I actually do a store
it then some
friend or enemy or anyone can come in
and for example put something into that
q so am it was very very hard and I hope
you sympathize with me psychologically I
style as to how hard it was for me to to
reconcile myself to the idea that the
whole thing completely breaks down kitty
in a usual style of reasoning it was it
doesn't apply anymore it was there
staring at me and I just couldn't accept
it so I also had to go into analysis and
counseling and so now I'll keep that
particular part so that's the general
issue can we bring concurrent
programming to the same level of
abstraction inconvenience as sequential
programming when I say abstraction
convenience I'm not sure it is
absolutely no irony in the index it's
okay it's okay a relative right as
compared to sequential to concurrent
programming secret reprogramming today
is really very convenient smooth
abstract easy organized structured and
so on well the world is not sequential
many more we as was already a clear from
several of the previous presentations
who want to do multithreading you want
to do internet I even added co routines
ID at the end here after the last two
presentations that it's quite a thing
that co routine seem to be last three
presentations it's interesting that code
team seemed to be coming back into
fashion at the moment I'm really
impressed so we want to do this now
there used to be this joke about object
like the programming in the early 90s
that is like teenage sex you know
everyone says they're doing it if you're
actually doing it end of you who are
actually doing it are not doing it very
well and this is almost true with
respect to concurrent programming except
that many are actually doing it which
makes things even worse and in fact that
is really the problem Andy that we
haven't done with respect to concurrent
programming what we have been able to
achieve with more traditional sequential
forms of programming if you look at the
major to revolution that have occurred
in the field name is structured
programming now even in the value sense
not a diceless sense but the vulgar
sense of removing go tues and staying
with high level control structures and
of course after that object technology
in both cases you have the following
characteristics Ohio we work at a higher
level of abstraction we know the
techniques the demonstrators they they
remove their books remove and add
restrictions certainly in the case of
structured programming no go to again
Val give you well and but you also add
some rare you also remove some
restrictions for example you know vector
into programming you can do dynamic
binding it's so it does things for your
dynamic binding is a good example for
this you don't have to do if there are
if car then do this if motorcycle do
that you things for you there is a
mathematical basis that's very important
in the case of structured programming
it's basically I mean flow hold
extra semantics and in the case of
object-oriented programming it subscribe
in a touch now they're this mathematical
basis is very important but it's also
important in the fact that there are
lots of people who do object-oriented
programming for example who have no idea
about after I genotypes and other people
who benefit from structured programming
who would not recognize a whole triple
if they found one in their bathtub when
coming out coming back at home at night
right so but still benefit from again is
still reason at a high level of
abstraction in particular and I should
have added this pointer to this list the
in your reason less operationally know
when well why is it good to remove the
go-to is that you don't have to think
about your program thinking I'm here
because I'm X might be equal to three
because I come from here I don't know
wait wait I'm actually coming from there
or I could be coming back from there so
this is very poor a very operational
mode of thinking and advances in
programming have been able to have
enabled us to use a less operational
more abstract more static form of
reasoning about programming and this is
this is exactly what has not happened
with concurrent programming and it's a
that implying any criticism at all it
was quite clear in the previous talks we
still talk about logs and new textures
in semaphore and so on which in a way
makes me feel younger because it's his
early nineteen sixty-eight waited we
know
there's a new streets of Paris trying to
deter burn the whole the whole place so
it's kind of now its pleasant feeling
again but and of course this whole thing
comes from from Dykstra anyway which is
kind of ironic but it's semaphores so
it's the concurrent programming
equivalent of go tues and basically if
you look at the threading models today
we know many are doing it but they're
doing it in the same way as in 1968 I
the level of abstraction has slightly at
all if at all been raised ok so it used
to be messing is still lazy where
sequential programming on the left is
less messy than it you used to be so for
example sweating models are the typical
exact ace and it's again completely
operational reasoning I mean if you if
you listen to presentations of how
threatening works in in what current
approaches you you have to listen to
things 22 comments of the form where ok
this X is going to be equal to zero
except that if we might have a data race
because this other thread Cal could come
in and so so this is just exactly as we
go to accept that at least with a
program involving go tues you can debug
it for you can test it when in a
concurrent case forget about it I mean
you can still make people pretend that
they are testing their concurrent code
but they don't believe it and no one
else we need it don't so that's what
we're trying to do to address we're
trying to come up with the ideal model
in concurrent programming and one of the
only ones to do it is to do this there
are research teams all around that are
trying for the same Holy Grail we think
we are better but so it it's not for us
to to to judge and certainly there are
some open problem so thats whats coop is
about now just give you a very short
very small example before i get into the
the details and also show you the the
way we've implemented whole thing and
on.net this is the kind of code that we
write in scoop so they I must say I mean
without any modesty whatsoever that I've
seen quite a few solutions of the dining
philosophers problem over the years but
I think it's hard to be this one in
terms of rough concise so basically
philosopher is thing and then they eat
and in order to eat to eat and you too
sorry I shouldn't be pointing on one of
the screens they need to forex left and
right and another so this does the
reservation and what was quite
interesting for me is that I wrote this
code I think almost 12 years ago foul
long long long before there was any
implementation in this code essentially
runs i mean i have this attitude of a
programmer who never ever believe that
anything is going to to run especially
but it does so it's exactly that code
well it could start a bit faster that's
definite yeah and like everything good
in the world we've had a few examples
already in the previous talks it was
this particular example was done by an
intern you know that thanks good things
god for interns so lets you have few
more philosophers so okay speed I'm
going to make them a bit faster there's
a philosophy speed in animation speed
and let's say I mean do the this is
actually a bit fast to see to see what's
going on and there's as far as I can
tell there is no deadlock I mean you
prove there's no they're not right here
has run for about 30 seconds now so
maybe what it's exactly the code that i
showed before and also i mean i'm not
have the time to go into the details of
the model edible but there is no notion
of active object I don't worry we'll
actually an active object active object
is really contradiction in terms if you
think about it if you if you think about
the basics of object technology so in
particular in order to get the kind of
active part we simply inherit from a
glass process which is a library Klaus
and I'm particularly proud of this thing
the rename set up as get upset up at the
initial operation of a process and 44 if
it also for its get up okay anyway so
the mechanism now starting in a slightly
more orderly fashion after this overview
mechanism is called scuba day it goes
back long into the 20th century and it's
now being implemented for for good at
ETH thanks in particular to to the
magnitude wrote or a funny it runs on
top of the compiler for dotnet so the
maybe I should mention it and here for
those of you who are not aware of it
that there is a full-fledged
implementation a rifle for that night it
was one of I think 11 can say that
together with COBOL it's the major
success story of languages available
commercially outside of Microsoft
languages on top of dotnet it's the
first version came out late 1999 and as
a commercial product about two year one
or two years later it's a full-fledged
implementation of a rifle taking
adventure is completely was very far
it's a less compliant completely
interoperable with other languages and
it has two versions one which is the
classic iphone Visual Studio
implementation so that's the that's for
people who dream I for think I shall
sleep I Foley rifle and who just want to
use iPhone net and the second one in
vision is the plug-in for visual
studio.net and the to project the
formats are compatible so here you can
go back and forth between the two so if
for example if you're more of a dot net
programmer who wants to use a little bit
of eiffel in your application then
you'll probably use an vision to mix it
more easily with other languages but you
can switch back and forth okay i'm not
going to spend very much time just
describing the basic concepts of scoop
since i want to talk a little more about
the implementation let me just take a
few minutes to to to recall the basic
concepts not so much I mean my dream is
always that p that the idea is in the
end up here so inevitable
that you know everyone redesigns the
whole mechanism with me that's of course
a bit unrealistic but I should still
hope that you can understand the either
reasoning the rationale behind behind
this whole thing so there are no active
objects as I mentioned the first time
anyone thinks of concurrency in the
context of Arabic technology there's
almost a universal reaction of saying oh
this is a marriage made in heaven it
should work as exemplified for example
by this comment by ramen Miller and then
about 30 seconds later you realize it
doesn't work do you have the desktop
similarities but the the impedance
mismatch is actually worse is bigger
than the seminary so if you take in
particular this notion of active object
this idea that you should make out you
should give objects their own scenario
the way actually it already was in in
simulated story I mean it was quite
innovative but I think that's the part
of simulate that doesn't transpose that
it doesn't scale up I like I love almost
everything else and similar this one
doesn't work because if you have objects
that have their own scenarios we hugely
so an object is going to do an active
object is going to do something a
certain process and then the other one
another object is how you pay to have
its own process but then an object is
also a repository of services available
to the rest of the world so maybe object
a is going at some point to require some
service some feature from object B and
then what happens they have these
conflicting agendas so and this is how
you run into all kinds of problems which
are heavily documented in Erie in the
literature they have one big advantage
which is that they're excellent as paper
producing devices but in terms of
practical utility it's more limited and
I think the evidence is there simply
that no object oriented concurrent
mechanism has gained wide acceptance
apart from these low-level thread
libraries that are we not object
oriented but that everyone uses so
that's what happens in practice
so let's take a let's take this take a
step back for a second to say something
very very okay and actually I'm saying
this because it's completely elementary
to perform a computation is to apply
certain actions to certain objects and
then you're using certain processors do
in order to be able to execute these
actions so the object technology has
been there basically to tell us that the
objects are more important for the
overall structuring of the code than the
actions but they of course both
necessary and we've tended to ignore the
fact that we have a processor although
we know it's there but in sequential
programming there's only one so we don't
need to to pay that much attention to it
and I would contend that what becomes
new with concurrent computation is that
we can have in fact several processes
and of course I'm taking the word
processor is an in an abstract sense it
could be a physical processor but it
could be a thread it could be an appt
domain it could be it could be anything
that can execute actions so actions and
objects so we the first rule that we are
going to take accepting that we have we
can now have several processes lots of
them zillions of them in the first one
that we're going to take is that all
calls on an object and of course in
object fighter programming what we do is
calling operations and objects Oh calls
on a particular object I going to be
executed by a single process so we call
it the hammer of the processor so this
immediate area rules out a few
interesting things like for example
object migration but it seems so
beneficial for simplicity and
understanding that I think it's
worthwhile we can always implement for
example of regulated migration migration
of a migration on top of that basic
framework but to to be able to reason
about the whole thing will put this
restriction so you see what I'm doing
I'm trying to to make the whole thing
manageable by putting enough
restrictions as needed I think this part
I'll skip well maybe not quite in fact
well sorry the what's nice about the
traditional approach to our vehicle
programming is that even for those
people who don't know anything about the
formal basis they're still just
intuitive understanding that if you have
operations in features in a class you
would have any things to prove so if we
don't prove things rated it let's say
their end things to understand so they
are independent now if we start having
interleaving then that's not the case
anymore the space of things to
understand explodes so again in this
period of simplicity I'm going to
require mutual exclusion though are the
various features meaning operations on
any particular object at any particular
point in time so this is also a strong
restriction and in fact it in practice
it's not as bad as it might appear at
first in particular of course if we
think of a really big object like a
database this is unrealistic we're not
going to let just one client access a
database at any particular time but
we'll have the restriction maybe on well
nobody the ways in practice is going to
be split into many different objects so
the proper V a restriction is not as big
as itself okay now we still haven't
really identified the key distinction
between sequential in concurrent so then
the next step is is to do exactly this
on by looking at a fundamental operation
about related programming which is
something I've it's x dot R with a
certain argument hey that's what our
regular program is due again and again
at the execution time so there's been an
instruction before and it will be
instructions afterwards and well the key
the key aspect here viewed from the
standpoint of execution order is that we
since we're doing one thing at a time
the call has to be synchronous it has to
be blocking in a sense that while we're
executing are on the supplier object the
rest of the computation doesn't progress
now the difference what's really new in
I think in a concurrent context is that
these two objects could be handled in
the sense jerz defined by different
processes so there's really no reason to
wait on the client processor and
actually if we always waited in one
might argue that there's no not so much
need for for having concurrency I mean
if we have a zillion computers but
they're all they're all waiting on each
other who
whenever they ask something from each
other why why just why not just have one
in a very fast processor very fast
computer so that's what we're going to
say hey we're going to say that if a
supplier envy handler of the supplier
object is a different one from the
supply of the client object then the
court is not blocking it's a synchronous
so we narrow down the distinction
between concurrent and sequential to
this particular point now of course if
we have a different syntax semantics
it's gradually usually considered in a
polite practice to have a different
syntax as well I mean we you could of
course tell the program very well you
know just wait until execution time and
you'll see what happens but that's not
too good so the general idea else i'll
come back to the slider dashes kid but
general idea is that if a call is going
to be handled by the same processor is
blocking otherwise not blocking which i
call synchronous and asynchronous here
and this must be reflected in the same
tax so in the second case will write
separate TX instead of just X to declare
the type so this is the only language
extension to eiffel that we have in this
mechanism that's it of course we we're
going to have some changes in semantics
as well but in terms of extra think that
that's it so coming back to what i do i
do the first rule the second rule cause
a non separate objects are blocking
calls on separate objects are non
blocking by separate object i mean an
object that is handled by a different
processor pro from my process and this
has been this has to be reflected in the
center so when we separate we don't say
which processor we just say it might be
another process that's good enough at
this point there's some consistency rule
let me just going to give you an idea
here let's assume that we have a routine
p which takes an argument a of some type
and then here we use a separate be so
the problem if i had a little more time
now i would actually ask this in the
form of a question maybe you've seen it
already there's a problem here which is
that a actually refers to a field of an
object if we look at it from the
after I have to remember not to point
apologize to the right wing members of
you of the audience please stop me if I
do this again me this a here for example
here I could do something like a dot F
ok and well a is a traitor I call a
trader an object that is declared as not
separate but which in fact is
representing I'm sorry let me start
again a call traitor a variable which is
not declare that separate but which
dynamically at one time refers to an
object handle by a different process so
we don't want writers basically so the
first rule for avoiding traders is
straightforward and I did not show it
here it's that when you are assigning
you value to a target you can assign
from not from non separate two separate
but not the other way around because if
we assigned a separate value to a non
separate or more variable then we would
have a traitor in the semantics that's
implied would be one here we have
another way of getting a traitor because
a is actually coming from from another
object but it's not declared at separate
so there's going to be a first rule that
says in such a case you have to declare
it as separate so the rule is here it's
a bit worthy for any reference actual
argument it doesn't matter for value
arguments what's called an Eiffel
expanded value for which there will be
copy semantics but either reference
actual argument the corresponding formal
argument must be declared as separate
now there's there's like four of our
rules of that kind I give you the other
one another one a second ago which is
the assignment or argument passing rule
and one of my students got Nina told
Nina tov ski started to dislike these
rules passionately because they're kind
of ad hoc so they're actually nice to
present like this in an ad hoc fashion
pedagogically but in the end they're
just they're just too too inconsistent
so he has devised as part of this
project a type system which makes the
with annotations with concurrency and
attention separate annotations which
basically resolves in us having just one
rule
which is having quite nice ok next in
almost last element of the mechanism
lets me I'm a programmer and I write
things like this where we're sorry X at
the top there's type we should say my my
stack
so I push an element on a stack and then
a little later I get the top of that
stack so if I'm a naive programmer I'm
going to think that I get back the
element 8 the element that I just pushed
and if I'm lucky of course that's going
to be the case but as before something
else can I that can happen in between so
you know people might say well big deal
the programmers need to be careful and
that's their problem but in the same
spirit of trying to remove bugs and make
things easier to control in primate less
operational reasoning we don't like this
so we are going to have a very stringent
rule which says that a separate cool
something of the form a dot F where a
separate will be permitted only if a is
a formal argument of the enclosing
routine so the previous call code is
permitted now only if this is a routine
on of which my stat x is an argument a
separate argument and of course as a as
an associated mathematic rule the the
routine will not execute until all these
separate arguments have been reserved so
this is the fellow metal object
reservation mechanism just past the
objects as arguments now this is very
restrictive and I think it's one of the
best things about the mechanism in
particular it means that all these
difficult issues of resource reservation
that otherwise have to be handled again
and again by each application programmer
and now taken care of by the mechanism
so this explained in particular like it
left and right a scheme of the dining
philosophers example which i think is
repeated somewhere in a nevermind okay
next well precondition that's what I
started with this cannot anymore be
considered a a correctness condition in
a normal iphone in design by contract V
a precondition is a correctness
condition so it is good as bad news for
the client because you have to satisfy
the precondition which is also good news
because it means that if
do satisfy the precondition then you're
entitled to the result well that's not
true anymore so this is why I stayed so
long at this and then I realized that
there's only one Pacific possible
reasonable interpretation which is to
make it a weight condition and actually
this is very shocking to many people and
we just really give will give you one
more thing about this because I'm
running quickly running out of time well
we've come to the conclusion the student
and and I that this was not only the
right cymatics in that case but oh right
semantics are in all cases that is to
say waiting is the basis of life right
waiting the base is correct so if you
have like here to preconditions one that
is a separate call you not buffering
buffering separate right is full in
second one which is your two plain
precondition value positive the second
one is awaiting condition as well except
that it's the company it's it's it's
urge that the smart compiler actually
even the stupid compiler can determine
that value greater than 0 R value is an
integer we will either be true now or
we'll never be true so it's useless to
wait so it's kind of a compiler
optimization to turn awaiting condition
into a correctness condition so I agree
this is a bit of the wall but I think
it's a style of thinking that makes a
lot of sense this basic semantics is
waiting and there are cases in which you
know it isn't helped to wait we you know
if ask you whether the integer X is
greater than zero here is greater than
zero now or it will never be greater
than zero because well it cannot be
changed so the full somatic rule is that
a separate precondition causes the
client to wait and actually full somatic
rule sorry is that the the co will
proceed when the older corresponding
object are available and a separate
preconditions hope ok one more mechanism
the last one resynchronization I start
you know X dot F in Tokyo I started X
dot G in Seattle I started y dot F in
Zurich and these are all non blocking
calls so when do i wait again well we
could have designed a resync realization
construct we did it the idea is that
when there is a query so the previous
ones where procedures could commence as
we call them in I
come in and procedure is the same thing
query means either an attribute or a
function in a nightfall there is a very
strict symmetry between attributes and
functions and like in most object 19
languages so there we treated the same
way so here i need the object do I need
a computation to be finished on X
because I need some value on X so this
is where we will synchronize this is
this idea doesn't compromise come from
research by Dennis caramel who is now in
ease and it's known as we call it lazy
wait I think he calls it wait by
necessity so clients wait for
resynchronization on on queries okay now
there's one more mechanism that I'll
just described very briefly it comes
from from a library rather than a
mechanism and it's not implemented yet
so I shouldn't talk about it too much
sometimes a an object holds another
object has a lock on it and you want to
kill it you want you to grab the lock so
this is not in a very systematic fashion
by triggering an exception for those of
you who are familiar with the field we
don't have expressed messages because
this is again this is the kind of thing
that makes it impossible to reason about
the software if we have exceptions and
it becomes possible okay the
implementation we have built the
implementation on top of that net
remoting and well I'm sorry this is this
is a plan this is not done yet that's
what we would like to have remoting e
and thread and threading we decided I
decided actually against the wishes of
the rest of the team not to do this at
the language level even though it's a
language extension we decided I I
decided to have it as a library because
I didn't want to spend a year grappling
with parsing and integration with the
development environment and so on so we
implemented a library called scoop lee
for anyone of anyone who knows who is
german you you'll get the inside joke
because lee is
of a Dominion friendly diminutive like
line I guess in German so for example to
cross all that you get in the morning is
in German is called a get fell but in
Zurich is going to get free so we
initially called it scoop lip but it's
now scooper bleah so that bad words i
think the right decision because it
enabled us to come to work on
concurrency issues not to work on
language issues in for example we just
very very it's enough to get a glimpse
here but on the left is actual scoop
code the way we want to write it on the
right is code using school play it
relies fundamentally on the iphone agent
mechanism which is a kind of which is
basically a closure it's a somewhat more
general notion of closure it's a like a
general lambda expression so this is the
code that initially we were writing
manually to emulate the code on the left
it became tedious fairly quickly so now
we now have a preprocessor that
basically takes coop code and translates
it into screw please so we haven't
updated the compiler yet but it will be
straight for it just really we working
from the front from the preprocessor
okay let me just show you to finish a
couple of examples of a rather example
we have a nice example i think it was
for you to decide of course that's
elevators now if i could have borrowed
the elevator itself because we actually
had a student by build with with lego
mindstorms and it's all construed
controlled by a computer Ronnie iphone
so we have this we show this to two
visitors except that it's rather fragile
so almost every time we use it we break
something and we have to and we're not
too good at hardware so we have to to
bring back someone to fix it so here is
the software version which does not
break so its elevators what's nice about
what's interesting about this design is
that it came straight from from my book
of Reclamation software construction and
once again it worked I mean it's exactly
the algorithm that was written there I
mean again I i I'm saving saying this
and may seem obvious but
have to pinch myself when I see
something and I wrote and which actually
runs on a real computer and not just in
my mind what's interesting about this
design is that it's completely
phonetically object oriented that is to
say everything is an object with and we
in every operation and everything is a
separate objects all these things for
example buttons in cabins you know every
cabin you can have a row of buttons on
every floor all these are separate
objects so it's fanatically object I
didn't so fanatically concurrent I'll
show you the number of threads running
in a second so let's create a few
elevators the elevators are fast so I
can do it manually okay so here there's
a customer so to speak who wants an
elevator it's very fast and now set much
very much for more fun to do it as a
simulation and it's going to start to
have people click all kinds of buttons
all over the place it may make it faster
um let's see if I can perhaps start a
manager hello where do I see the number
of thrice I always forget is in
performance yeah so just this it created
yeah only that's not too many but we we
it's care what the point is that he
scales up we we have gone all the way to
several tens of thousands I think of
sprites and it won't work so let me also
show you another thing that will be the
final fingers push it should stop this
thing weighs a time maybe this is an old
implementation we used to we used to
have you know busy weight which is not
too good for performance this has been
fixed since then yeah they produce a
consumer example is the archetypal
example of a view of using preconditions
as wet conditions because basically the
the consumer has the has the
precondition not empty and the producer
has the precondition not full and that's
the way it works
dude I didn't start or something yeah so
actually done by the same as this is a
master's project I think all these
examples in the meantime I will show my
conclusion slide so is it coming back
oh yeah there's actually two of them
oh no ok I I killed the wrong one
start again
so I'll show it to you too I'll show it
in the end so as a couple of words of
conclusion we with we feel that it's a
model that makes concurrent program
we've we've done lots and lots of
examples there are several master's
thesis report that you can find on our
site which but we cover all the oldest
edit examples i mean a non standard
example of cocaine on programming and
you know we fail in terms of
expressiveness in simplicity and clarity
we fare better on song and worse on
others but really overall i think it's
very impressive how we can do concurrent
programming at a high level of
abstraction we don't yet have real-life
applications well what we have done is
these examples but on the basis of those
examples which I extremely diverse we're
very enthusiastic about the future the
goal has been to excite object
technology with general and powerful
supports and to make programmers sleep
better so the status is everything is
implemented on top of that as a result
of this project so any we were quite
happy with the way the result the duels
are will be implemented win the next
three or four months everything is
available for download we I'll repeat
the the URL in the next time which is
also denounced and we also have numerous
examples available for download so all
those which I may or may not have the
time to all those which I showed in
those which I did not have the time to
show you can all download the
executables we of course very grateful
to to this project for fulfilling we
also have felling from a Swiss
foundation as the foundation and the
Swiss notion National Science Foundation
now what remains to be done we still
have lots and lots of things I mean the
more we do of course the more we see
what else we have to do there's the
stuff system so that's on a more
theoretical side I think it's too
complicated at this point but I think
it's the right direction we are working
very actively if I had had more time I
would have shown this to on the
application of the model to distribution
air web services we have interesting
work going on I think we can completely
get rid of that log something that we
don't do well in the model it's a bit in
indirect
then we have to improve the the model is
think that for example CSP or the old
model of Jay misra do very very well
it's waiting for is waiting on the first
of several events that's where you at
csb showed very well in da delivery
mechanism winner too good at this so we
we need a bit of progress there i'd
really like to put my hands on the
compact framework this is really where
the future is as far as i'm concerned i
want to put this on phones on RF IDs and
kurds and so on so that's I can't wait
to be able to do this we have again on
all of this I have things to say it is
ongoing worker I prefer to in this talk
to concentrate on on what's already
there and solid and well understood but
there's all kinds of things going into
kinds of different directions so we are
working in extensions for real time and
in the integration with a compiler is I
don't see it as a major problem I never
say this when there's a member of the
compiler group in the group in the
audience but then they're not here so
these are the two this is the place
right this is the place where you can
see the downloads the papers and so on I
also took the opportunity to mention the
work that we're doing for introductory
teaching or another big project that we
have with you with our also some support
from the curriculum initiative is
introductory programming well where we
use using some fairly revolutionary
techniques and some of this work as an
influence on that so and let me sleep
with my buffer came up and then that
will be it why didn't come a point out
you're right
how it is so now it should sound oh yeah
in it okay so few producers
and okay so maybe should be a really
fast producer and what let's see so yeah
well the the demo itself is just a
producer consumer what's what's really
interesting is is the code which which I
didn't show you a full detail but it's
essentially this idea that you have a
put operation and has required not is
full as a precondition and a get
operation that has required not is empty
as its preconditioning that's it now
that's basically it it takes care of the
synchronization and of course I should
have found I think first well it's not
that exciting with a big buffer and
relatively so producer but you you see
the idea any questions if we have time
for questions
we usually floated introducing nope
how many hours do I have now yeah so
wait to make it very sorry I should
maybe shouldn't have worried but I
believe very much in this is the right
way to teach programming in a nutshell
we want to to have a modern introduction
to programming modern in the sense that
it prepares students for the challenges
of some time feeling like you're
forgetting but it still sound
scientifically so and also I see this
very much in the context of the way the
use of industry is going and I teach
switch students I think it would be the
same in the US or in generally
industrialized countries if I just teach
them programming I don't think they have
much chance ten five years ten years
from now against not people from st.
Petersburg who is going to be paid as
much as they are pretty soon but you
know there's always going to be someone
cheaper with the same skills so the idea
is to train them to be systems thinkers
and in particular to to work with large
amounts of code so what we've done is
develop a huge wealth fairly huge by
economic status pizza of software which
is a really which is a general graphical
multimedia system for the application
domain is traffic in a city and we throw
these two hundred thousand lines of code
to them at them under on the first day
of the course and and then they learn by
progressing from consumer to produce it
so we emphasize obstruction in contracts
and interfaces and specifications and
adt's right from the start without
necessarily using pompous words but
simply by showing them that they can
actually produce exciting interesting
exciting
visually visible visually impressive
programs life on the start by relying on
this huge library which again is
multimedia graphical animation and it
does really impressive things and the
first program they write is going to be
10 lines but it's already very
impressive because it uses all this code
and are able to use this code precisely
thanks to to abstraction so I instead of
pontificating about abstraction which
every computer science professor does
and meet me to a bit of course I try not
to but I try to show them that thanks to
the power of obstruction and interfaces
and contracts in particular they can
produce these interesting applications
and then little by little they go from
the insider from the outside in that is
to say they learn to see how it's done
internally and this also has a big
practical advantage which is to solve
one of the major problems we face today
in teaching introductory programming
which is the incredible variety of
previous experiences of students you
have some who have no barely touched a
computer before and you have some that i
have written an e-commerce server in the
tens of thousands of lines how and i'm
the first phase that they see at
university basically how do i teach to
go to both of these groups and everyone
in between without risking losing some
boring the others well this business of
giving them lots of software means that
the novices can really do what they're
supposed to do and approach the
difficulty by step so this also means
that I can avoid losing some some
students which I would otherwise but the
more advanced ones right from the
beginning they start jumping into the
code of course it's all given in so
available in source they don't have to
do get a source because they they can
look at the interfaces but if they want
to look at the source they will end it's
amazing what I do so this there's
another URL which which I would which I
would encourage you to to look at our
problems yeah its gates very easy its
games don't teach eh12 maybe i can even
show it
me from via right well I'll just bring
up this page you can always take and
take the microphone you can always cut
this out but the these absolutely 60
games that's 60 different groups of
students have produced well it's in
about four weeks they have very little
time for the project and it's it's not
even greater they did it for the fun I
think you can see the identity the what
students are able to to do n are asked
I'll stop use games of you th then the
next this in the next couple talks will
have a couple questions of ample time
discussing for them